I just want to reiterate the mayor's
thanks to everybody for coming today and
I'm not going to take much time because
we really do want to stay on schedule
and I think Mayor Dinkins provided us
with a perfect introduction for the for
the day's panels this is a particularly
important time in American history and I
just want to reiterate that i want
everybody to focus on that and i want
everybody to understand that part of
today's discussion needs to be carried
on after we leave this forum the idea
today is to get some of the best and
brightest minds in public service which
we've managed to do to talk about the
prospects for the economic recovery in
our region everybody here knows that the
new york metropolitan region including
new york and new jersey and nassau
county has been very hard hit by this
recession and it's going to take a lot
more than simply washington promising us
things that they tend not to deliver on
for us to work our way out of this
recession it's going to be the voices of
the people in this room and the
brilliant ideas of people who are on our
panel today so i am not going to take
any more time because i think it's
important for everybody to hear what
we're about to hear from this panel I'm
going to briefly thank sepa and
especially the Rockefeller Foundation
for supporting our forum today which we
could not have managed without really
the support of Darren Walker and his
staff in the Rockefeller Foundation and
I want to thank my colleague professor
Dorian Warren who's going to be
moderating this panel I when I came back
to Columbia I was sort of saddened by
the prospect of going to a new office
and not being next to people I had been
next to for probably 20 years professor
flora Davidson who's here today and Dean
cafeina trakis and I really didn't think
I was going to meet anybody that could
they can't take their plan
but at least entertain me inform me and
educate me Dorian Warren he's managed to
do that and I'm just grateful to have
him as a colleague here at Columbia and
I know those of you who have had his
classes know what an extraordinary
professor is without any further ado I'm
going to ask Dorian to come up and
introduce his panelists thank you
everybody for coming today Thank You
Esther for that very lovely introduction
thanks all of you for joining us we have
a panel this morning or this afternoon
of what we think are some of the most
innovative and transformative leaders
and so you'll be hearing from them
briefly the first panel today we'll
focus on President Obama's economic
recovery agenda from the metro region so
we're going to hear from the mayors of
Philadelphia Trenton and the former
county executive of Nassau County I'll
briefly introduce each of them there
longer BIOS are in your programs Michael
Nutter the 98th Emir of Philadelphia has
set a course for America sixth largest
city aimed at growing the regional
economy in a sustainable manner
dramatically improving Public Safety and
investing in education and Workforce
Development he is without question one
of the most innovative mayor's in the
country since taking office in January
2008 he has implemented a crime-fighting
strategy that has seen a sharp decline
in the homicide rate and continuing
reductions another violent crime he has
committed the city and the Philadelphia
School District to increase the school
graduation rate by fifty percent in five
to seven years and to double the college
attainment rate in five to ten years and
in respond to the deepest recession and
generations he has launched the
nationally recognized mortgage
foreclosure program that links at-risk
homeowners with housing counseling and
related services born in Philadelphia in
1957 Michael Nutter grew up in West
Philadelphia with his parents who
instilled in him a deep interest in
community service his sister and a
grandmother an academic scholarship
recipient he graduated from st. joseph's
preparatory high school and in 1979 he
graduated from the Wharton
of Business at the University of
Pennsylvania following Mayor Nutter will
be mayor Palmer Douglas Palmer took the
helm of leadership and Trenton New
Jersey the capital city of that state on
july one 1990 Trenton's first
african-american mayor mayor Palmer has
been reelected four times since to lead
a sustained revitalization effort that
has reshaped neighborhoods Lord
unemployment and initiated sophisticated
innovations across the spectrum of
municipal government he is the former
president of the National Conference of
Democratic mayors and most recently the
immediate past president of the
bipartisan United States Conference of
Mayors provide extraordinary leadership
around issues of national urban policy
Mayor Palmer is born and raised in
Trenton he's a graduate of Hampton
University in hampton virginia where he
received a Bachelor of Science degree in
business management in 1973 last but not
least on our panel is Thomas Suozzi who
served as the Nassau County Executive
from 2001 to 2009 he is a government
reformer attorney certified public
accountant and former eight-year mayor
of Glenn Close in Glen Cove excuse me
mr. swazi was named governing magazine's
2005 public official of the year for his
innovative initiatives in Nassau which
has a population of over 1.3 million
larger than 11 states and a 2.5 billion
budget greater also than 11 states
before mr. swazi came into office nassau
have been rated quote the worst run
county in the nation within a year he
turned a 428 million dollar deficit into
a balanced budget leading one of the
most successful financial turnarounds in
the country he eliminated wasteful
contracts cut the workforce of the
smallest in 30 years and achieved
historic labor concessions Nassau is the
only County in New York that did not
raise taxes for five years in a row and
that received 13 bond upgrades in five
years more than any County in the nation
he is a graduate of Boston College and
four times School of Law so let's
welcome our three mayor's as we begin
dr. Warren thank you very very much and
good afternoon everyone now I I mean I
fully understand I don't bring the star
power of chairman Rangel but he be a
little bit of break up here he is
definitely a tough act to a tough act to
follow let me just say first it really
is an honor to have been asked to
participate in the in mayor Dinkins
annual Public Policy Forum here at here
at Columbia Columbia as i mentioned to
to my good friend victoria for all
across the nation and around the world
tremendous reputation as a educational
institution and i'm really enjoying my
my time here and of course any time
spent with Mayor Dinkins for those of us
in public service I had the occasion to
meet with him shortly after I was
elected but not yet sworn in and it's
one of the most memorable meetings that
have had in my entire public service
career he is in fact living history and
I know that you get a tremendous benefit
from him dr. pukes thank you very very
much and I complimented dr. Fuchs from
the earlier session her ability to just
stand up and cause people to collapse
there are there questions whatever it is
that they're talking about I haven't
thought I haven't seen a look like that
since I was about six from
from Catalina Nutter and I knew exactly
what that meant and i mean i was i was
about to sit down myself so so my two
colleagues up here Tom and in Doug and
David Stone Maxine Griffin I didn't
realize I knew so many people here at at
Columbia let me talk a little bit about
a little slightly smaller city to the
south which Liam I came here today
notwithstanding the fact that just a
little while ago this great city and I
admire your mayor tremendously this
great city hurt my feelings quite
significantly back in November we were
all prepared for back to back and just
kind of didn't work out congratulations
to to New York in the in the World
Series let me talk a little bit about
the nation's first capital and the
soon-to-be fifth largest city in the
United States of America also known as
Philadelphia I came into office in
January of 2008 coming off a big general
election win and about eight months
later the federal government shared with
us that the Great Recession as we refer
to it at least in Philadelphia had
started in december of 2008 i was 2007 I
was elected in november two thousand
seven and no one was kind enough to
mention to me that the country had just
gone into recession which we found out a
few months later but notwithstanding
that we started to figure that out
actually that something was going on as
early as this spring of 2008 when we
noticed that our real estate transfer
taxes had just taken a precipitous drop
and actually had adjusted our estimate
even in the spring of 2008 all the other
tax revenues were going in the right
direction which was up or at least
according to to estimate but there was
something unusual going on
on the real estate side we made our
adjustments kept going on put forward my
first budget on Valentine's Day I gave
out actually roses to the members of
City Council was a new day a new way as
great period spirit of partnership and
friendship and made investments in the
police department fire services EMS
emergency services community college as
a doctor mentioned I'm kind of big on
education our community college had not
been getting a proper level support and
Philadelphia made investments there from
a park arts and culture restored the
office of art and culture which the
previous administration had actually
closed said I would do that during the
campaign and did that and a number of
other things by the summer of two
thousand eight we really knew that we
were having a problem because all the
other tax revenue sources had also
started dropping like a rock this had
not yet been named so we didn't know
what was going on and on September
eleventh two thousand eight just
happened to be the day I decided to
announce it a citizens of what we were
seeing during the course of the summer
they needed to know publicly the city of
Philadelphia was experiencing at least a
450 million dollar deficit over our
five-year plan Philadelphia on like
virtually any other city in America we
not only have a balanced budget
requirement in our home rule charter but
according to state statute we actually
have to produce five-year plans and
every year in the five-year plan must
also be balanced it's great for fiscal
discipline it's terrible if you want to
do one time fixes or move money around
and get the budget and the five-year
plan all approved by a state oversight
entity appointed by the Commonwealth of
Pennsylvania the governor and each of
the four legislative caucuses in the
General Assembly so they don't mess
around and they have the authority
actually to withhold certain funds from
the city if they don't approve our plan
so we take it's called pyka Pennsylvania
intergovernmental cooperation agency
that's why we call in pyka because no
one wants to say that
more than once a day we take them very
seriously and on our way at least to the
2008 world series we had to make a
choice after telling the public that we
had a 450 million dollar five-year plan
deficit in September that the number had
grown to 650 to 850 we then gave a range
in October and as the Phillies were
marching on to the World Series and as
we were about to experience the most
historic election in most of our
lifetimes we decided that
notwithstanding our public announcement
that we would give the public the final
number at the end of October we didn't
think it was too bright to announce that
what that number was in the middle of
the World Series and the election and so
two days after senator Obama was
president-elect we announced on november
six the city of philadelphia was now
seeing a 1 billion dollar five-year plan
deficit a hundred-million-dollar current
fiscal year deficit and it was the
largest gaping hole in our city budget
mid-year in the city's history we took
swift action we had had 13 straight
years of wage and business tax
reductions in the city I've been a
leading advocate for reducing the tax
burden in Philadelphia for over a decade
and other than laying people off the
toughest decision was to announce that
we were going to suspend our tax
reduction program for the first time
since Edwin bill was mayor that we would
reduce the size of the government cut
back on a variety of services some
layoffs and significantly reduce our
costs we actually closed that gap in
December swift action by our city
council in a number of changes that we
made life went on January came new
budget coming around we pushed that
budget back because we had done so much
a significant harm to our city services
that we wanted to give the public an
opportunity and I don't really strongly
recommend this for any of you thinking
about going to public service we had
eight town hall meetings to listen to
the public's concerns about what we had
done and to get their insight about what
we were about
do in the upcoming budget those are
wonderful sessions two and a half hours
500 plus people to scream at me for two
and a half hours to tell me and our
administration just how stupid we were
it's a it's a it's a quite unique
experience but we used that time to then
have more focused workshops that I did
not attend facilitate it and gave the
public an opportunity to try to figure
out the same dilemma that we were trying
to figure out which is take a hundred
dollars and assign points to various
services and you the public try to
figure out how to balance the budget
what more police wonderful tell us what
you're going to cut you want law
libraries open love libraries when all
the rec centers open all our swimming
pools everybody wants and once and once
and once we gave the public an
opportunity to have an exercise in a
facilitated workshop how to balance the
budget virtually no one could without
either dramatically cutting services or
raising taxes most public opinion polls
not our's show the public at virtually a
50-50 on whether the city should cut
taxes cut services or raise taxes which
is pretty much where we were within the
administration and we were in the middle
of in the first year I was in office jun
30 as the end of our fiscal year well in
July 1 jun 30 year all four of our
municipal union contracts were expiring
on jun 30 at the same time we
subsequently got one year contracts out
of all of our unions because we did not
want to lock in long term again context
we didn't know what was going on but we
knew we didn't want long term contracts
turned out to be a pretty genius move
again everyone thought that we were
pretty stupid to to do that we took one
year contracts they wanted multis we
wanted one we got one and pretty much
kept the status quo because what we
really wanted to do was to focus in on
the two biggest budget busters at least
for our city our pension and health care
costs pension and health care costs
consumed twenty-five percent of the
entire city budget for the city of
Philadelphia and we needed to get that
on
control and so we took the one the one
year contract in an effort to basically
buy ourselves a year and a half of time
to be able to focus in on those issues
and I'll come back to that in a second
since 2009 up to the fiscal year 2009 to
the current year we've cut 218 million
dollars in spending we reduce the size
of the government by nearly a thousand
full-time employees and we continue to
not only shrink our government but also
reduce our costs but we did have some
good things happen at the same time and
so managing through the financial crisis
you still have things you need to get
done the government doesn't close you
can't put it on temporary hold and say
we'll get back to you as soon as we
figure out what else is going on so
while that was all happening during the
campaign Philadelphia unfortunately saw
its crime rate going up a year after
year after year New York City and a
number of other cities across the
country their crime rate was going down
there are five of us in the Democratic
primary I said that we could actually do
something about it most the other
candidate they said well may take five
years may take ten years I said that we
could actually do something about crime
in eight weeks that actually got a
little attention and people either
thought he's really smart or there's
really something wrong with him here are
the numbers in two years that I've been
in office homicides are down 23%
shootings were down eleven percent last
year every major crime category in
Philadelphia's down over the past few
years we hired the best Police
Commissioner we could find I think he's
the best in the United States of America
other than Commissioner Kelly and his a
good friend and I we've learned a great
deal from him I actually talked a lot
about New York City in the course of the
campaign that if you could reduce your
ha massage from 10 years ago to over
2,000 to somewhere between four and five
hundred and you have eight times seven
eight times the population of
Philadelphia that we could actually do
something about prom on education
college attainment college degree
attainment is up three percent as well
as graduation over the pass
a couple years and we serve a lot of
work to do we announced greenworks
Philadelphia back in April our plan to
make Philadelphia in number one green
city the United States of America
recycling when I came in office was at
seven percent it's now at plus sixteen
percent and growing last year we were
paying recyclers to take our recycling
thirty-three cents a ton out of the city
a month ago the market changed and in
our favor they now pay us five dollars
and four cents a ton to take our
recycling we announced single stream
recycling a year ago and that is gone
pretty well and this month today starts
Philadelphia recycling rewards a new
partnership with recyclebank which is a
company actually started in Philadelphia
the more you recycle in your
neighborhood by areas you'll actually
get coupons discount cards and a variety
of other exciting givebacks much like
some of the credit card companies do
we're actually going to give people back
in the form of those kinds of things
money or certainly a card to spend
things on if you recycle recycling saves
us money both in landfill costs sixty
eight dollars a ton to put your trash in
a landfill versus now five hundred five
dollars and four cents to collect it we
said that we'd started 311 context
center much like new york and chicago in
a number of other cities we said we do
it in a year and on december 31st 2008
we opened our 311 call center for about
2 million dollars in there a bunch of
cities across America trying to figure
out how we did that doctor mentioned our
mortgage foreclosure program Mayor
Bloomberg actually invited me up to New
York last year when he announced new
york's mortgage foreclosure program
which is modeled after Philadelphia's
program and a number of other cities and
states across the country have sought
our information or sorted program
similar to ours we're trying to convince
the White House to scale it up and take
it national because so many hundreds of
thousands if not millions of people
continue unfortunately to lose their
homes lastly an idea that I
and so much steal it I did ask
permission and always give him credit
mayor daley in chicago created the
mayor's metropolitan caucus i was out in
chicago in 2005 on a exchange visit it
was one of many many ideas that i took
out of chicago but took that one and put
it in effect we now have a metropolitan
caucus in the five-county region of
philly bucks Chester Delaware Montgomery
counties all the county commissioners
and myself 15 of us meet now on a
regular basis we actually for the first
time filed a joint application to get
ARRA funds and the White House is
particularly interested in metro areas
that are working in partnership and I
thought we could use economic recovery
dollars as the driving force it's
amazing that how money can actually get
people to cooperate and we use it all
the time a lot of talk and that's mostly
what it is about the economic recovery
act whether it's working or not yes it
is working could it do better of course
it can can any government program do
better of course it could probably a
couple things you'd like to do better
here at Columbia maybe not but every
public agency can always do better at
what it does we'd like the money to come
quicker the feds do enjoy making award
announcements in cities we love making
receipt announcements and there's a
little bit of a gap between when it's
announced then when we get it we just
like having the money we have received a
bunch we're still waiting for more but
there is a lot of confusion out in the
marketplace we're cutting services
laying off workers with the raise taxes
last year a temporary increase in the
sales tax and the public is trying to
understand if you're getting all these
millions of dollars from the federal
government why are you still cutting our
services and laying people off and so
you know as the saying goes you know yes
we can on economic recovery those we
have to say no we can't we cannot use
them to plug our budget holes states can
cities can a little bit of difference
there and so that's what governor's do
it took the economic recovery dollars
plug their budget holes
try to keep services in place while
cities are either raising taxes laying
people off cutting services or all of
the above that is the big conundrum and
challenge for us and we actually have
the bodies you know that eighty percent
of the country's population lives in a
city seventy-five percent of the gross
domestic product comes from cities I
love all the other six or six counties
of the Commonwealth of Pennsylvania but
philly Pittsburgh Erie Centre County
Scranton and a couple others are where
the people live if you spend the money
where the people are you'll actually
save jobs or create jobs and turn this
country around in some instances we've
seen I mean in cities as i said to Mayor
Dinkins earlier and a couple and the
Chairman rankle you know in cities we
don't have bridges that go to know where
they all go somewhere they carry people
and commerce and all kinds of other
activity and so if you spend the money
in cities you'd actually get something
done so that's been a big big fight and
my good friend Doug Palmer probably talk
about that as well unemployment
unfortunately has gone up in
Philadelphia we're now at eleven point
two percent and unfortunately we expect
that it might continue to grow welcome
to feds do for cities 1 i've had all
kinds of meetings with all kinds of
federal officials including at the US
Conference we were just an hour with
President Obama and Vice President Biden
we're not asking the feds just to write
a big check and send us money but we are
asking for is use the formulas that
already work CDBG the new ECB g & CSBG
or give you all these acronyms these are
all programs that exist they work they
get the money directly to cities you can
even go and do some old stuff you dad's
revenue-sharing no issue no controversy
some of them were actually even started
by Republicans many many years ago and
so what we're asking for is a new
relationship with the federal government
that cities are where the action is and
cities are what will bring this country
back set all the money to banks
investment firms auto I have no
complaint there all I'm saying is you
claim that they were too big to fail we
say we're too important to fail and
we're
credit risk because we don't go out of
business no one has ever gone to
Washington turned over the keys of said
hey you pick up the trash you run the
rec centers you do whatever you do in
cities we take care of our business and
so we're asking for a little more
creativity of a treasury with tarp funds
that we have numerous unfunded mandates
clean water I love clean water we have
some of the best water in the United
States of America as a matter of fact
our water is cleaner and healthier and
more regulated than that water in that
bottle right there because the federal
government ensures that you want us to
keep it clean wonderful send us the
money to upgrade our systems to make
sure that America's water supply is
clean cities cannot do this by ourselves
lastly everyone is not going to work on
a bridge erode a highway or sit on a
backhoe I love infrastructure as much as
the next person public service
employment will put a lot of Americans
back to work very quickly when i go back
to philly today i can assure you when i
get out of my car up on City Hall
sidewalk I can assure you that no one is
going to walk up to me and say mayor I
need some health care the person is
going to say is may I need a job and I
have to be able to walk in North Philly
west philly south philly or any other
place in the city of philadelphia and if
they're five guys standing on a street
corner be able to walk up to and say you
want to go to work today and have a job
ready and waiting for them that will put
millions of Americans right back to work
and it all happen in cities and so we
need to change the relationship with the
federal government we are not the enemy
we are in fact are the solution thank
very good good afternoon it's it's a
dread for me and I've done it on many
occasions follow my good friend Michael
Nutter after he speaks I was hoping I
could go first but I'm second so you
know that's just the way it goes it's
great to be here and I just want to say
this you know Mike Mayor Nutter was
talking about all the great people that
are here and we're speaking and he said
hey man how did how did how did we he
said we he said how did we ever get
invited to this and I said I know how
you got invited because you wanted to
premier mayor's in this country he's
only been married two years but i'ma
tell you being his neighbor in Trenton
New Jersey which is the state capital
law he's one of the outstanding mayor's
in this country and I know because I'm I
was a president of all of them and and i
can tell you he is one of the greatest
also mayor bloomberg is also a great
mayor you have a great innovative mayor
here and I'm just very glad that he
every now and then gives me some some
great advice he's here because he's
great I'm here because my relationship
with my godfather right here mayor
Dinkins you know mayor Dinkins and my
mother played together a long time ago
and he's from Trenton New Jersey and
we're very proud of him and he has
always been there to answer the call for
me whenever my mom would call and say
you know David my son's running for this
or that I've been blessed by my hometown
not only be the first african-american
mayor but I've been elected office 32
years and so a lot of it is due to this
man who come whenever I needed him and
what a great feeling it was to have a
trenton native person that never forgot
where he came from to be elected the
first african-american mayor of New York
City and Mike nada was telling me New
York was probably one of the last of the
big cities to elect an african-american
and he became mayor and he took me
around in 1990 when I ran to be the
first african-american mayor of my
hometown he came in campaign for
me raise money for me and the day I won
the night that i won he was the first
call I made in the second call was the
barber Sigmund my dear friend was a
mayor of Princeton who was related to
hell Boggs it was hell Boggs's daughter
and Cokie Roberts sisters so those are
the two people i call now let me after
saying all that it's great to be here
but you know when you marry your
hometown you know lived here all your
life and then like I said I've been
elected 32 years and I've been blessed
to be mayor 20 years now you know
everybody in the city knows you were not
great big like New York where to stay
capital but everybody knows me and
that's great Mary you know you know but
there's a blessing and a curse to
everybody knowing because sometimes when
you just want to get in you know go to a
store and you just want to get in and
get out you just can't you can't do that
and this one day I just wanted to get in
and I wanted to get out and I could lie
to y'all you know I could tell you I was
going to CVS or you got what Dwayne me
door I could tell you I was going to the
farmers market but you know I was going
to liquor store and uh you know I was
going in the hood you know I'm in the
hood I was going to liquor store I got
to support all of my neighborhood
businesses but I just wanted to get in
and I just wanted to get out so I you
know put my collar up night you know i
have my head down and soon as i put my
hand on the door i hear a voice mr.
mayor yes sir he says guys you a
question and I said look brother you
know let me as I'm going to hear you
know when I come out you know I'll be
glad to answer any question you had and
I was in there so long that I really
forgot that he was even outside and as
soon as I walk out I hear mr. mayor mr.
mayor damn can I ask you a question now
I said you know yes sir what's the
question he said mr. mayor I want to
know what's the greatest nation in the
world I said what's the greatest nation
in the world united states of america
you know my country tis of thee sweet
land of liberty
says no sir it's not I said well brother
what's the greatest nation in the world
and he looked at me right in the face he
said mr. mayor the greatest nation in
the world is a donation I said all right
man you got me on now in here brother
here here here here but you know he was
right because sometimes a person could
have blessed with money and they can
donate to causes other times they can
donate their time and what America's
cities are saying is that you know we
want a donation but that donation is an
investment and just to tell you Mayor
Nutter talked about the stimulus funds
and certainly what his city's going
through mine on a much smaller scale as
doing that as well we're dependent on
state monies this is state capital
fifty-three percent of Trenton's
tax-exempt the state owns forty percent
of our land and so we have certainly our
problems and when the state revenue goes
down it has a trickle-down effect on us
we've had to do what mayor's all across
the country do and that is to lay off
people to look at furlough some people
furloughed the cut services and do those
kinds of things because you just can't
tax your way out of it so we've done all
those all those things but when 2008
came and I was present in United States
Conference of Mayors we had senator
Obama who had gotten a nomination at
that time he addressed the nation's
mayor's and he said something that I'll
never forget and that's true he said and
there was a question asked about did you
hear the word cities mentioned well I
didn't really hear it but he said that
day in front of the nation's mayor's
that cities or the solution not the
problem and he's exactly right it's like
that famous bank robber or Willie Sutton
you know I asked him Willie why you rob
banks and he said that's where the money
is you know mayors are saying you know
you know when you look at eighty percent
of the gross domestic product being in
the metropolitan areas of cities that's
where the people are so it makes sense
that that's
where you have to invest when we look at
our funds that are coming in and one of
the problems that we have in as mayor
nutter again said you know people look
at all this money or tasty announcement
not when you actually get it of all the
millions of dollars are coming our
constituents are saying well you got you
got all that money you know why you
laying people off fact of the matter is
folks that city's only received directly
one percent of the ARRA funds just one
percent and so we see that you know in
order to get America back to work in
order to strengthen the metro economies
you're going to have to put the funds in
the money where the people are and as we
met with President Obama a year ago we
met with him just last week we told them
and we told Congress congressman rangel
our dear friend knows and speaker Pelosi
and Senator Reid we told them a year ago
if you want to get people back to work
which is critically important you're
going to have to give some of the money
directly to cities and we know how to
spend it could and we told me said look
the states and look I love the state's
you know I love I was going to say I
love our governor we had a new governor
now corazon got beat I like our governor
I didn't say I dislike him I like him
right now you've been in office two
weeks we'll see but we said the states
are just going to take that money that
you give them and they're just going to
back hole their budgets and that is a
lot what they did or if there was
transportation money to came through
instead of you know built you know
parceling that money out to upstate here
you need some votes I'm not saying it
happens in New York or even New Jersey
i'm tom by other states other state but
instead of parsing it out there and
building roads where you have more deer
than people invest in our crumbling
infrastructure which our engineers have
said we've got a d-plus in terms of our
infrastructure bridges collapsing put
that money where the people are where
the jobs are to have money come direct
and so as we look now at a second year a
year of stimulus we're looking at the
house and the Senate passing a jobs bill
the United States Conference of Mayors
and mayor's across this country led by
your mayor and others are saying that we
want to have monies direct and there is
a formula that's been successful just do
it like the CDBG program which has which
has helped which was always threatened
to be cut double CDBG have that money go
through cities because we already had
the mechanism to put it out and that can
create jobs right away our energy
environment block grant which Mayor
Nutter talked about is something I'm
quite proud of under my presidency and
it was if we want to green the city's
the mayor's have to lead the way but we
don't have it in our budgets to provide
that so like CDBG we wanted the energy
environment block grant that would be
formula based which it is coming direct
to cities that has helped us create jobs
as a matter of fact I'm going to name
see I decided not to run again 20 years
is enough of being mayor of my hometown
but before I leave in June we're going
to name a new courthouse which would
putting solar panels on because of that
money to David and Dinkins courthouse so
and and so we're using money there we
also use money in a cop's program which
came direct to cities which enabled us
to do to either hire additional cops we
hired 18 additional cops in Trenton or
save the police officers that you have
if you saw early last year Mike Coleman
and mayor of Columbus and now said he
would be able to hire i think it was 40
cops that were not going to be hard as a
result of it the other thing that we're
talking about an infrastructure and
getting where the jobs are and getting
monies direct to cities and of course
i'm not a politically naive i understand
that you can't just give all the money
to the cities but we want to change the
the pie instead of eighty percent going
to the states and 22 the cities you know
let's make it 50 50 or 55 to us 45 to
them something like that so that we
could take money we have projects right
now infrastructure projects green
projects that we could get the bids out
right away one of the biggest problems
and if it wasn't and
care what people say if it wasn't for
President Obama doing the stimulus it
wasn't for Congress passing it we would
be in depression right now we wouldn't
be talking about the recovery we'd be
talking about how are we going to get
out of this depression and so people
could say all they want but they had to
do what was necessary to stop a
depression and get us moving forward but
the statistics tell us that it won't be
until 2014 until our unemployment rate
is going to go to seven percent early
this year it'll still be a 10 by 2011
the estimates say it'll be a little
above nine if you want to change the
paradigm look at investing in
infrastructure clean energy and having
some money go direct to city so we can
get the money out and be held
accountable their type yeah you can go
it thank you thank your for me about the
tiger grants you know this this is a
some discretionary money unfortunately
an mayor of Mayor Nutter said this you
know what would you say Mike you said we
want change you know we've talked about
change but we don't want it
incrementally we want it now we want big
change and the tiger grants great
there's 1.2 billion dollars in the
budget for tiger grants that would help
you develop your infrastructure and
create jobs 1.2 billion in a budget
fourteen hundred cities apply now what
are you going to do get seven Tiger
grants if you have 1400 cities and mine
was one of them mayor nutter's probably
was I know Mayor Bloomberg if you have
1400 cities apply instead of 1.2 billion
if you want to create some jobs quick
we're saying the funded 57 beam that's
what you need fifty seven billion
dollars to fund these projects that are
approved that will get people working
get development happening in cities and
create jobs and payroll taxes we're
looking at school construction the same
way get it directly so the weakens begin
to build schools and so these are the
kinds of things we're talking about as
well as summer jobs for many years you
know we summer jobs were cut and people
are saying on
and kid juvenile crimes going up I mean
it's not rocket science you know you
take away opportunities for people
you're going to have those kinds of
problems last year in the budget for the
first time in years there was 1.5
billion dollars for summer jobs three
hundred thousand young people got to
work low-income individuals who would be
standing or sitting around in street
corners it targets for trouble and those
things and you know what they do you
know y'all got kids you know kids got
get their money they're not putting it
in our 401k you know they're spending it
and that's what you need them to do and
so this year they cut the money in half
about 500,000 and the mayors of this
country are saying fully funded the 1.2
billion so did you can continue to hire
more young people and so there's small
business money have money go direct to
small businesses that will create jobs
and look I know Mayor Dinkins knows the
county executive knows all of us now
look government's not government's not
going to create jobs the private sector
creates jobs we are just a way of
helping prime the pump we don't expect
us to just you know give us money so we
can have more government jobs we're
trying to reduce government what we're
saying is we want to be able to invest
in our infrastructure and clean energy
have contract go to the private sector
small businesses so they could grow
their economy so that we can create more
jobs and that's all it's about if you
leave here today and say what did Doug
Palmer talk about he said he talked
about going to the liquor store no he
talked about a donation and the nation's
mayor's are talking about a donation
back to cities so that we can invest and
create the jobs that is so needed in our
country thank
Thank You Mara Palmer mar swazi thank
you very much for inviting me here today
I'm very you know mayor you were talking
about how you didn't know why you were
invited here today another was saying
why was I invite I don't know why I was
invited here today I I called a pastor I
said Esther why you invited me to come
here why did you she said she said with
your brilliant we wanted someone smart
elected official and we couldn't get the
mayor of Rochester to come I'm very very
happy to be here and I'm very pleased
with the introduction I receiver Bree
said my name right if you saw my name in
the program it's suo zzi tom suozzi now
people never get my name right when i
was first elected as County Executive at
national County I was the first Democrat
with a democratic legislature since
nineteen seventeen so it was a very big
story the Democratic National Committee
had a party here in New York City I was
invited to the party Danny Farrell was
one of the hosts of the part of that
night they said the new county executive
from Nassau County Tom Susie I looked
over my local chairman I said Jay I said
President Clinton's here if President
Clinton gets up there and calls me Tom
Susie I'm gonna be known as Tom Susie by
Democrats throughout the country from
now on so President Clinton gets up
there he starts to introduce all the
elected officials he never mentioned me
at all I said Susie would have been okay
so listen I'm doing great already I'm
very happy I I'm the former county
executive of nassau county i just lost
my election by 386 votes point2 purse
less than point two percent of the vote
out of 250,000 votes which was down from
three hundred and sixty thousand votes
the first time I ran and the reason I
tell you that is because we have to look
at the context of all the things we're
talking about we want to see change we
want to see the world may better we're
concerned that the disparity between
rich and poor is getting bigger every
day we're concerned that disparity
between those that are well educated and
those who are not educated is getting
worse and worse all the time not just
economically but according to all the
social statistics you look at we're
concerned about global warming and we
want to
see things happen regarding climate
change we want to see investment in
clean energy we want to see better
investment in our infrastructure we want
to see more movement towards mass
transit and away from roads we want to
see change but this is one of the
toughest times for chains to take place
because the public's in a very bad mood
what happened up in Massachusetts what
happened in the last November like my
election I was up by nineteen percent of
the polls no indication that i was going
to lose this race but the public's in a
bad mood so you've got to compare two
different times throughout American
history and there was a book written
back in the 1980s by Arthur Schlesinger
called cycles in American history and he
talked too bad how there's a dramatic
movement in the national psyche of
America every 30 years you can compare
1920 1952 1980s that goes from self
interest to public interest and back to
self interest again self-interest often
singh has been more conservative public
interest being seen as being more
liberal and then back to self interest
again so what's happened here in America
over the past decade we've seen some
very big public interest type things
where the public was very involved in
the national conversation sep tember 11
2001 everybody was involved people
wanted to do things unfortunately the
president at the time asked us to go
shopping instead of change our nation
dramatically but the public was very
interested in what we doing is what are
we doing as a nation what's their place
in the world Iraq and Afghanistan the
recession even the 2008 elections
everybody was very involved in the
public conversation I would argue that
much like the 80s and the 50s and the
20s we're going to see starting now in
2010 more and more inward-looking
self-interest people don't want to know
what you're going to do with health care
reform as the mayor pointed out people
aren't stopping him on the street about
that to talking about jobs people don't
want to know about how you're going to
dramatically change all the different
things that don't affect them personally
right now immediately I want to know
what do you do from
job for my family for my taxes from my
this my that they're very concern skin
its legitimate I mean they're afraid
people are afraid about the future about
the economy and about their place in
life and you won't it'll be tougher and
tougher I believe over the next several
years for us to do big broad public
change because people are going to be so
concerned about just what are you going
to do for me right now for me so that's
one thing we have to keep in mind when
we look at this the second thing we have
to keep in mind is that what the federal
tax policy is currently federal tax
policy started mainly during the New
Deal under FDR and later on in the Great
Society under Lyndon Baines Johnson that
said the blue states everybody knows
maybe the blue and red states right
raise your hands you know at me about
the blue and red states is run us even
okay not already know the younger people
ona okay this big thing the elections
back in two thousand the Northeast the
Rust Belt the west coast are the blue
states the Midwest the southwest of the
southeast of the red states there was
really Democrat Republican but there's
an interesting phenomenon you have to
look at based upon federal tax policy
that was set up under the new deal in
the Great Society we said our blue
states are so successful and we're doing
so well and we've got so much money from
our economies being so strong that we
can afford to contribute to the national
federal government and help the rest of
the country to catch up with us catch up
with our economic policy with our social
we're full policy with our environmental
policy with our civil rights policy with
our health care pal you we can invest we
can subsidize the rest of the country to
help them to catch up with us but what
happened is that now most of the blue
states are donor states we give a lot
more to the federal government than we
get back most of the red states with the
exception of Texas arnette taker States
they take a lot more than they give no
wonder they're against all the different
federal policy we want to do they're
making out like bandits anyway with our
funding we're subsidizing the rest of
the country and at one time really made
a lot of sense but right now wouldn't we
love to have our money back here in New
York State or
back in New Jersey or back in
Pennsylvania that are massive donor
states to the federal government in New
York State this is a study that was
started by senator senator daniel
patrick moynihan right now we said 55
billion dollars a year more to the
federal government than we get back
wouldn't governor paterson love to have
ten billion of that back right now out
of our 55 billion so we're sending all
of this money to the federal government
to subsidize the rest of the country
that's really before the recession
started was growing by leaps and bounds
compared to us while we were just trying
to hold on for dear life so we've got to
be looking at that in the context of
what we're talking about when we want
money back in our cities you know one of
the reasons I'm here is because we can't
just talk about cities anymore the mayor
talked about in his remarks about the
metropolitan region and how important
the metropolitan region is when you look
at the major think tanks in the country
Brookings Institute is one of the
preeminent ones talks about how we look
at the Metro regions and the top 100
Metro regions in America of once New
York is number two Los Angeles is number
one the top 100 make up two-thirds of
all the people and two thirds of the gdp
and you'll be much more effectively
effective politically if you get new
york city for example to team up with
Nassau County in Suffolk County in with
Westchester County in rockland county
and even over to Newark and other
northern parts of New Jersey and then
you've got the different regions that
you're each in your metro regions okay
metro regions will be much more powerful
and effective in getting public policy
change if they could work with each
other and they're the ones who are
donating all this money to the federal
government that they're not getting back
so keep that in mind so what Mayor
Nutter and Mayor power talked about as
they face these difficult Financial
Times there's only two choice you know
there everything is so complex it with
budgets for local governments not that
complex either have to raise revenues we
have to cut expenses that's the only way
to balance a budget raise revenues or
cut expenses that's happening all over
America unfortunately when you raise
taxes or raise revenues for governments
getting it from the people or the
businesses or you cut expenses often by
cutting programs or jobs you are not
stimulating the economy you are
contracting the economy so why we're
talking buddy talk about stimulus
stimulus gnomic stimulus local
governments had a contract contract
contract which is why it's so important
that the federal government invest in
local governments ten percent of the
employment in every metro region in
America is from public employment
whether it's teachers or cops or
healthcare workers a youth board work
whatever maybe ten percent of the
employment is in these areas and some of
the most dramatically affected by the
devastation of the economy so we saw in
the first round of stimulus money we saw
a big investment in Medicaid didn't help
you guys unfortunately it helped the
city of New York help the counties in
New York State cuz counties in New York
are in the city of New York have the
terrible policy when compared to the
rest of the country in that we only get
fifty percent of the money from the
federal government for our Medicaid
programs for federal programs every
state in America but in New York State
we only get fifty percent of the money
from the federal government and in New
York State uniquely 25% comes from the
state mailer 25% comes from the city's
city of New York and the counties and so
when that Medicaid money came it plugged
the big hole in a lot of the budgets and
I think that the president will probably
do it again because 2011 is going to be
devastating for the states and places
like New York City and the counties in
New York State again because their
pension costs are going through the roof
because everybody's pension funds are
invested in Wall Street Wall Street got
killed so where did the money come from
to pay for the pensions the taxpayers
have to pay for it so that's a whole big
new set of money they need to have and
because the stimulus money was going to
be gone for the Medicaid program it's
different in the other cities we need to
see investments in a couple major areas
one are these direct subsidies to States
and as the mayor Mayor Nutter and Mayor
Palmer both pointed out they need direct
operational subsidies
the city's because the states are
getting operational subsidies through
this Medicaid money and through some
education money but the city's needed as
well because if you want to stimulate
the economy you can't be doing a
counterproductive program of contracting
at the same time in the cities and they
need direct option operational subsidies
now that doesn't mean they're not going
to tighten their belt they've been
tightening their able to continue to
tighten their belt as everybody in
America has to do but it's so gargantuan
a change in such a short period of time
and most of the stuff is mandated you
have to do it anyway that you need to
have that money so first is this
medicaid / education / public safety /
whatever direct subsidies to states and
local governments to counterbalance the
contraction that would otherwise take
place secondly you need money put into
transportation I would argue you can't
let it rely on the same old boring
formulas that have been used since time
immemorial which makes it much easier to
invest in roads and much harder to
invest in mass transportation there are
dozens and dozens and dozens of rules
and processes and procedures you have to
go through to invest in mass
transportation and roads it's pretty
straightforward and we know know that
for the benefit of our quality of life
the benefit of our economies and the
benefit of our environment and health
mass transportation is something we need
to invest in and you know what it's
probably more in the blue states where
the cities are on top of that number
three we need to invest in education
because of the fact that we're going to
see our state's cut their education
funding dramatically and we know that in
order for us to compete in the global
economy and in order for us to stop what
is this growing disparity between rich
and poor educated and uneducated we've
got to do a better job educating our
people probably one of the toughest
challenges to do right now because it's
not a benefit you're going to see in the
short term and last but not least we
need to see investment in green
technology because green technology is
the future for this country on and we
can't just argue from the benefit of of
the environment I was the New York State
2008 environmentalist of the year for
the New York League of Conservation
Voters okay I believe in the environment
and we have to save the environment but
we're not going to get everybody to
believe in the environment so we have to
make the other arguments as to why it's
important to invest in green technology
the other reason is we need to stop
using so much foreign oil because it's
ruining our we're sending all this money
to countries and places that want to
destroy us and we're paying for it by
sending all of our oil money to those
countries we got to get off this kick
and start moving towards green energy
and it's the new internet as far as the
economy goes it's the new next big idea
it's a thing that will put people to
work and you can't you can't outsource
jobs to a foreign country to replace the
windows in New York City you can't
outsource the retrofitting for solar
panels you can't outsource the changing
of the lights you can't outsource all
the different things that you need to do
to make our buildings greener so from
every perspective the environment Public
Safety in foreign policy and from jobs
in the economy we have to invest in
green technology now all of these things
are going to be very hard because
everybody's in a bad mood and the
republicans are taking a very big
opportunity to go after the president
and the Congress and the Senate to say
you're not doing anything and when they
try and do something they don't do that
you know the health care reform is a
great example of the whole thing we've
been talking about health care reform
for 50 years in our country president
debated it throughout the campaign with
Hillary Clinton and then in the mate in
the general election campaign he came he
says we're to do health care reform you
moving too fast talked about it the
whole time whenever you want to try and
change anything whether its
infrastructure education green
technology changing and funding formulas
there will always be people that benefit
from the existing situation that benefit
from the status quo they don't want
change because they benefit from the
current way and while we're all busy
doing our stuff going along every day
they're working hard as they can to
protect the status quo the way it is now
so change requires the smart people in
this room who spend their time coming to
conferences like this who are well
educated
who are dedicated to making the world a
better place to live in who want to see
things get better for all the people to
keep on fighting to keep on pushing to
keep on using your education and your
passion and your desire to make things
better for everyone if we keep on doing
that will make the change we need to
happen thank you thank you thank you
Miss swazi we have a short amount of
time about 10 minutes for Q&A so I want
to arrange it as such will take a few
questions from you right here at the
microphone 30 seconds or less this is
the professor Fuchs model of questions
will take a few questions and then we'll
let the three mayor's respond and then
we'll close out the panel for a short
break so please my name is Alice LaBrie
and I'm a constituent of congressman
Charles Rangel real quick I wrote a
letter to Peter Orszag the budget
director because he was at NYU
expounding on the need for college and
etc but I've raised the issue in a
letter etc not everybody wants to go to
college and not everybody can so I asked
him she challenged them to have tell me
what is the president going to do about
vocational education thank you I just
like first of all thank you it was very
insightful I didn't hear anything about
charter schools what are the
opportunities while the challenges
around charter school in your district
city I'll of charter schools and I think
the I think the President does as well I
mean one of the challenges in
Philadelphia we have more charter
schools than any other school district
Pennsylvania loves government alive we
have 501 school districts in the
Commonwealth of Pennsylvania Philly has
more charters than anybody else one of
the challenges is the funding formula
disadvantages the rest of the district
but other than that charters work well
they're a choice option for parents it's
another way to keep folks with their
child in public school my daughter goes
which is a regular public school amount
of charter but so I mean I don't know
that the feds are going to do anything
in particular about charter schools I
think the bulk of the ARA dollars are
going for a school construction you've
got race at a stop race to the top
grants and that kind of stuff but I mean
you know education is at the heart and
soul of turning around any City Joyce
Miller and I do consulting on
infrastructure financing energy and
transportation pension funds investments
in infrastructure basically the question
is there are a number of initiatives in
Congress in the last year and that are
still alive for this current year and
some of which have actually been
presented over a number of years which
would address some of the concerns that
you raised about infrastructure
financing ranging from the energy bill
which Steve Israel as tom suozzi nose
has been very actively involved in and
creating opportunities for
infrastructure financing and energy the
reauthorization of safetea-lu which has
been put on the back burner by the
administration which would also include
large sums of money for new
infrastructure and transportation but it
seems to me that from what you gentlemen
were saying this morning this afternoon
that one of the possibilities is to
provide support for the members of
Congress who have been involved in these
initiatives and even in other things
like the proposal for the national
infrastructure bank which you would
benefit from would be some sort of an
alliance among the municipalities and
local official opal government officials
in the Northeast region to put men put
pressure on members of Congress that
members of the Senate and also some of
the committee chairs who have been
somewhat recalcitrant in looking at new
ways of financing and I would just
wonder what you would think about
establishing such an organization as
opposed to
these National councils which encompass
too many issues too many interests let's
take this final question here I was
interested in your thoughts on the
national infrastructure bank and how it
might help you in changing this
relationship between the federal and the
cities and the funding that could be
used great and I'll add one more
question to the panel and that is I
believe the president announced his
budget today and so I want to know from
you all of you talked about the rest
investments in cities but in a national
environment where there is a sense that
the federal government has to attack its
own deficit what additional challenges
that pose it impose upon each of you for
investments in cities well obviously the
federal government and I mean president
announced i guess it was last week that
some kind of freeze on some amount of
spending i mean as we said earlier
whether it's local state or national
although they're very very different I
mean it does at a certain level come
down to the two fundamentals which is
the same principle in business I mean
you're either going to increase your
revenues your sales your market share we
have to significantly cut your costs I
mean it's I mean you don't have to be a
genius it pays to be smart but you don't
have to be a genius to do this so I mean
I want to go back to is I have to get
this out just in terms of a fundamental
and not to be partisan about it and I
know we want to be bipartisan and you
know I work with Republicans back in
Philly and in the in the surrounding
area but on the federal level you have a
Democratic president Democratic House
Democratic Senate and we were down in DC
the other week there was all this you
know i guess the conference start on
wednesday i come in on tuesday i had a
meeting with some folks over the
Treasury Department trying to convince
them of having eight cities just from a
pure borrowing standpoint utilizing tarp
funds you remember those funds that went
to all the banks and the investment
firms and everybody else except us and
unfortunately Tuesday had just happened
what's happening and then Wednesday the
conference starts all this obsession
about 60
60 60 and oh my goodness and that we got
to change healthcare because the 60 of
them every fourth grader in the United
States of America knows that 59 is
greater than 41 that 257 is greater than
178 I mean let's be serious people can
talk all day long you read the phone
book you read the Bible you can read
whatever you want to read but 59 votes
is a majority in the Senate and if
people want to filibuster and have all
this conversation while people 46
million Americans still don't have
health care while you're debating the
issue the unemployment rate is at ten
it's in high double digits in many
communities of color african-americans
and Latinos jobs and all the other
problems in this country a couple of
wars and all the other things going on
and we have to make people vote that's
why you're in a legislative body make
them vote every day it just have fights
and have debates and at some point in
time the American public so get tired of
this nonsense you have the majority's
use them so I'm for the infrastructure
Bank we need money back in cities our
infrastructure is crumbling I cannot
afford to pay for all of that
infrastructure our pension fund got hit
by seventeen percent loss in the past
year not because we don't know how to
manage money but in early January of
2008 the market was still in upwards of
13,000 on the Dow Jones at his low point
it was at 6500 we lost seventy percent
in value and we actually still beat our
benchmarks as insane as that sounds we
actually did better than other pension
systems but that cost me 500 million
dollars over the next couple years that
I don't have right out of the general
fund over to the pension system it's
less recreation less libraries less
please less far less of everything and
we have no means of making up those
kinds of deficits in the near term
that's why the federal government has to
get back in the business of cities use
the power that we have and run over them
and if i could i can't be more
articulate than Mike I just want to you
know go back to something is there's no
way I filed this young man there's no
way you should lose good elected
officials like this and some others and
I think people you know talk about the
courage of your convictions and those
kinds of things and I think it has to be
rewarded when you have people to want to
take on special interests whether it's
the police unions of fire unions whether
it's the teachers unions if you want to
look at real change it look at race to
the top or I know that secretary Duncan
I get Duncan and Donovan mixed up Duncan
education unknown both but Duncan from
midget education there's a move afoot to
try to have more mayoral control than
some instances that's a good thing and
some it's not but if you're if you're
still going to be restrained by unions
and not being able to do these things
are those things it's not going to
change and if you have elected officials
whether they're in Congress and Senate
county executives or mayor's or even
people on City Council that want to
stand up and do what's right they have
to be supportive I see people well I
don't have to go to city council
meetings thank goodness on that you know
but I hear tales that it's a good piece
of public policy that goes through and
three people will show up and say no and
it will turn around some people that
they told me they were voting for what I
said what happened three people came
three people hey you think you can
operate a phone but we're in a dark
you're gonna you know you have to be
able to sit well some people came yeah
you know a lot of times more people or
for things they don't come right you
know and I think it was smart i believe
the right thing on our yeah it's
critically important when you see the
president stand it up and do what he
does when you see even Mayor Bloomberg
stand up to look at some of the things
that he's fighting they had to be
supported and so folks I think this is
up to all of us to do it and like Mike
Nutter said Mayor Nutter said 59 is more
than 41 make them vote vote don't be
paralyzed by this and continue to fight
that's what made our nation great and
that's how we're going to get back to
having the good folks win because you
know the only way that bad things happen
is if you know good people do nothing I
don't want to start talking about evil
and add so i wanted to change a little
bit because they're all good people but
that's the way things happen and if you
don't start coming to meetings or
standing up and talking about this is
wrong then we're going to be in an even
worse situation just quickly on the
national infrastructure bank you know
the way the idea behind it is that we
start putting money in a more flexible
entity that can reward investment to
those places that they think will have
dramatic change and make things better
instead of with the way we do it now
which there's 108 different federal
transportation programs 308 programs
it's absurd you know they should be like
no for programs there's 108 different
programs and over the years law was
passed the things by and they just
accumulate over over the years 108
different programs and you know
high-speed rail is great that they just
invested a bunch of money in that that's
a great thing you know one do it every
way you learned in certain places you
need to invest in Freight there was just
an article in front page of our local
paper news day out of Long Island today
about how afraid is gone up trucking has
got so much dramatically accidents
amount of dramatically on Long Island
but you have to do have a freight a rail
freight rail program or it'll just keep
on getting worse that's a lot of places
in the country that have that type of
problem you have to invest it again in
mass transit you know and not just in
highways and make it easier to do so you
need to do things like congestion
pricing even though I know everybody
hates that idea but if it got to do it
so but change is hard and right now you
know the angry talk that we here now
like the Tea Party moving you here right
now now the talk has always been there
that's not a new movement
they've always been a small group of
very angry people out there talking
about how things really stink okay the
problem is is that people are listening
now because people are upset and they're
scared and they're finding there's
nobody else speaking to them except for
that voice they're finding the receptive
fertile ground so there's got to be a
also equal i want to say loud but
equally effective voice that talks about
why change is important because you know
i saw my race what you see what you'll
see in a lot of races is that less
people are showing up because they're
just numb like this whole thing i was
talking about before about you know
everybody's just exhausted from all the
public interest stuff we've done people
will not show up and those jula do show
up will be people that are angry so it
really has to you know it's important
that it's pollyannaish sounding but you
have to get this conversation going a
little more intense and i think that
what Mayor Nutter said before is a very
interesting idea in keeping with the
idea of the president showing up and
confronting people that oppose him
directly and having the conversation it
move the conversation forward maybe we
need to have that conversation in
Congress and let if people filibuster a
lot of people debate and let them have
it have at it you know and go back to
what we really believe in American
probably know people will actually do
the right thing because I believe that
people are basically good well on that
hopeful note no pun intended let's thank
our panel mayor's Palmer Nutter and
swazi